what's happening people welcome back to
the show it is a 1.5 million subscriber
Q&A episode it's been a while since I
did one of these it's been a busy few
months so I apologize for the absence
but we got thousands and thousands of
questions I've tried to compile them
there were a lot that were kind of
similar so I've tried to put a bunch
together and I'm going to get through as
many as I can so let's get into it
beyond the mic how do you deal with
negativity on the internet I this has
been the year that I've tried to rail
against cynicism I just I hate it I hate
it so much reminds me of all of the sort
of narrow-minded very defeatist
mentalities that I I really didn't like
it's all the worst parts of the UK and I
don't like it I I deal with it on the
Internet by following as few people as
possible so on Twitter I think I follow
a 100 people uh I don't spend that much
time scrolling Instagram and my YouTube
feed is relatively well curated so I
just try not to see it that being said
said when it comes to comment sections
and stuff it's difficult like I wrote
this thing the other day which might be
I guess interesting at least to listen
to um Fame doesn't change you it just
changes everyone around you is this
quote from Lis Capaldi in a documentary
and I reflected on it a lot this year
identity lags Reality by one to two
years there's a lot of psychological
Fallout from a rapid change in status
that's from Mark Manson it's jarring
when everyone else tells you how great
you're doing because you don't feel any
different but the world now sees you
differently it's like identity
dysmorphia and because you forget
compliments but remember insults any
increase in exposure mostly just feels
like an increase in criticism at no
point on the journey to becoming heavily
scrutinized does anyone teach you how to
deal with scrutiny there is no training
course for fame or criticism you're just
as vulnerable to it as you were when you
started but people presume that you
accepted the deal of criticism when you
decided to build a platform you didn't
and that's kind of how I feel at the
moment criticism is rough and negativity
on the internet doesn't feel very good
especially not when it's directed at you
so it is a learning process I suppose
and that's like perfectly true what I
just said there there's no training
course there's no point between having
150 subscribers and 1.5 million where
someone came along and like bestowed on
me the skills to be able to deal with
negative things you just like I don't
know hope for the best along the way but
I appreciate all the people that are
positive cuz you really do
help
ste. vrd hello Chris congratulations on
the 1.5 million how is your book coming
along and when can we expect it so there
are two books in the works at the moment
one will be something similar to a more
broy version of 12 rules for life modern
wisdom style Almanac book still thinking
about the value set for that but I'm
super excited like all of my news that
stuff just gets me super excited about
that and then the mating crisis with
David bus between those two you will
have one within the next it'll be
completed within 6 months and it'll be
published within 12 so probably start of
25 there'll be something
out s m l Ln smallen do you use any time
blocking methods to manage your time I
know I should Ali abdalah keeps telling
me that I should uh and I'm about to
switch my productivity system system
from omn Focus to tick tick if you
listen to the cinema the Christmas
episode that I did with the boys in the
living room you will know oh by the way
for the people that don't recognize
where I am like what what's this place
that I'm in this is my bedroom in
Newcastle the house that I've still got
in the northeast of England this is
where it all started literally sat right
here different mic different camera
different desk different everything
terrible lighting there was candle
stains on the ceiling which Douglas
Murray famously pointed out and everyone
thought was mold and the Entre entire
world was criticizing me about mold uh
but yeah I'm back for Christmas I'm back
in the UK I'm back in Newcastle it feels
very strange um to be back here it's
it's really funny for so much to have
changed and for you to be in a place
that's so familiar and for you to feel
quite different in some ways and also
still be the same so yeah it's uh it's
wild but this is where we are look we've
even got the same we got the same
lighting you can kind of see that's the
vertical bookcase we tried to replicate
all of this when I went to Austin so it
may seem like Austin was just something
we did out of nowhere and then the
cinema episodes have tried to match this
teal and copper color we do that on the
big episodes so it's all stemmed from
this this was the Genesis right here I
hope you like it um time blocking
methods yousef's going to teach me how
to use Tik tick that should integrate it
I know that I should time block more I
use my calendar quite liberally uh but I
should time block stuff that doesn't
appear on the calendar typically more
like tasks the answer is no but I'm
guilty and I think that I should Tom
bainy what's the biggest change for your
next live shows brackets thought they
were great thank you for coming Tom um
biggest change for the next live shows
I'd love to do some more production it
was as raw as it gets it's me in front
of a screen that's got my name on it
talking for 90 minutes and then doing a
Q&A so on stage on my own which if you
told me I've done that a year ago
would have terrified me and still kind
of did um but I would like to add a
little bit more production in uh some AV
stuff you know uh montages uh maybe even
scenes from the stuff that I'm talking
about you know if I bring up a quote or
I bring up an idea or I bring up
something we could maybe illustrate that
behind me or uh even like cut to the
episode and the point in the episode
where I learned about it that could be
kind of cool love to integrate some
music some like touchy feely ascending
kind of things but right now I just want
to like dial in my ability to feel
comfortable on stage especially to crack
jokes and do bits and do comedy
is a whole other ball game but yeah
that's I'm just working on the craft for
now I think we can add fluff and do all
the rest of it when we try and do the
the O2 in London or something big but
for now just dial in the craft seesaw
seesaw why didn't you do anything for 1
million
subscribers fair question there uh yeah
I kind of promised you guys a while ago
that we would have this like really nice
Montage put together or that we would do
something special and being honest the
last five months I can't remember when
we hit one million Subs maybe five
months ago the last five months have
just been
unrelenting uh internally there's a lot
of just not uproar just like work that
needs doing it's all really fun and I
love the guys that are working alongside
me but it's just so much man like I've
paid quite a high personal price this
year to get the show to where it needs
to be and that's largely been with very
limited time off and a lot of travel and
not much time to kind of chill and turn
my executive function off um so largely
it's just because I didn't have time and
that sounds like a bit of a cop out but
we didn't and given that we're now
closer way closer to 2 million than we
are to 1 million I will endeavor to do
something actually special uh for 2
million Subs I promise I will try I will
try my best uh furry puff skin
6585 do you think that you still have
some of the party boy character in you
yes uh that degenerate lives sort of
deep down and it's very rare that he
comes out I think he came out once last
year maybe once or twice last year yeah
twice twice last year and no times I I
think this year uh but I've got stago
bachelor party for the Americans uh
coming up in itha next year I'll have
another trip for
George's 30th in Miami on New York so
there's a couple of times where he just
he crests and sort of Peaks his head
over the surface and comes back down uh
but that was a huge part of me man like
that was you know for a decade and a
half professional party boy is not just
like a cool way that I put it like I was
a fullon did generate for for a good
chunk of my 20s
and it was very formative and I think so
many guys are like how many guys don't
just send it for a good chunk of time
and that was my career my career was
being a party boy like I literally I ran
the event I was the guy in the front
door with the massive afro that
everybody knew so yeah he's he's still a
part of me uh he just is he's on
extended Hiatus at the moment
potentially full retirement use a tl4 40
C5 do8 L need a better username first of
all congratulations thank you massive
love for what you're doing secondly if
you went back in time let's say late
teens early 20s would you be able to
appreciate all the struggle and
negatives you went through to reach the
positives or do you believe it is
necessary to hate the negatives so that
you have a motive to turn it into the
positives not entirely sure what that
means say would you be able to
appreciate all the struggle and
negatives you went through to reach the
positives if you went back in I don't
understand why I'd need to go back in
time uh I'll answer it as if I am now um
I think that having a chip on your
shoulder and trying to prove something
to people that doubted you or you don't
like or you feel like didn't like you or
shunned you or
unrequited care or love or whatever it
is I think that is important and uh
oh there it is again he needs to drink
those of us
that see the solo episodes know that I
need to drink I think that the action
threshold that you are required to do
that you need to reach in order to do
great things in order to really do
anything that's kind of difficult you
can have the pleasure and the positive
drive to go forward and you can have
sort of distaste and chips on your
shoulder and a hatred desire to push you
from
behind and a blend of the two seems to
be best it's not a fuel that you want to
use for too long but it's very very
effective at getting you off the line
and that's something that I've managed
to do and I'm now working on
casting off the negatives and kind of
that required to prove myself
sid7 are you planning on having Lex on
your pod also by any chance since you've
had a few comedians will you have Nick
Mullen or Adam fredman on Nick Mullen I
messaged two days ago uh we were dming
back and forth I think someone on his
team was dming me don't know whether it
was Nick um so yeah I'd love to get Nick
on I think Nick's fantastic uh Lex we've
been talking back and forth I messaged
him and congratulated him on the Bezos
episode I thought that was really good
if you haven't listened to that you
should go and check out Jeff Bezos on on
Lex's podcast and uh yeah I mean Lex is
a busy guy and like gets he's got other
things on his mind like for 18 months he
was like really personally impacted by
Ukraine and that's a bigger priority
than me bringing him on we'll get him
eventually
TMC candles 7 Chris firstly I greatly
appreciate work and a continual
Improvement in the guests and interviews
thank you can I make a suggestion the
titles of your podcasts really fail to
capture the essence of the interviews
and I have missed many a great
discussion for instance your Patrick P
David interview titled why does no one
trust the medor anymore did not remotely
capture fantastic discussion my best Tim
Tim that's a [__] awesome way to
deliver criticism uh very well balanced
and I appreciate you for doing it yeah
so look titling and thumbnailing on
YouTube um I touch I might be setting
myself up for a problem in future here I
touch every single title and thumbnail
that goes out every single one of them
and I think we have 2,000 videos two two
and a bit thousand videos on the on the
Channel all of them I've touched the
reason for that is I think it's very
important to frame the episodes and the
channel is an import in an important way
let me give you an example Russell Brand
Russell Brand's team knows how to
lytically hijack whatever's going on but
every single one of those titles make me
cringe inside they the it's horrible
it's horrible like they are coming for
your kids what you don't know what they
did it's like oh God guys come on like
it's it's the most antagonistic tribal
it's it's not
good I don't want to play that game
there's also different ways that you can
do uh titling whereby you put you kind
of keyword plug different things um Lex
Lex kind of does say it's on almost like
a list it's a listicle and we've tried
all of the different ones ultimately if
you're not happy with the titles that
we're giving stop clicking on them
because we split test things on the back
end we split test tons and tons and tons
of titles and we know which ones people
click on now obviously there is a way
that all of this could just end up
toward like the Russell Brand limic
hijack thing which we don't want to do
so we have it within confines we have
parameters of where we're going to allow
the titles and thumbnails to go to and
beyond that we don't take it there
but ultimately the titles are the the
titles and thumbnails are the things
that people click on because we need to
play Within the game of the algorithm
you're right maybe uh why does no one
trust the media anymore doesn't capture
a fantastic discussion but like what
does that gets people to click it's very
difficult like we tried it's like you
know Patrick Bet David a conversation on
the challenges of modern like modern
culture and media and whether or not he
should run for president it's like no
one clicks on that we tried
so I would be interested in a solution
that helps us to hold on to CTR whilst
also uh sounding good but for a very
long time I fought with titles and
thumbs and improving them made a massive
change to the growth of the channel I
don't think that we played the Olympic
hijack game that much we very regularly
the boys the copywriters that work for
me jod and Chase um will come to me with
something and I will say no I'm not
prepared to cross that particular line
which is totally arbitrary and probably
would get us more plays in fact would
almost certainly get us more play and I
come in with my big like hammer and
whack them down and say no sorry too
much can't have that too antagonistic
too tribal to whatever too accusatory
like we've done too many titles that
seem like that even if they work so we
work really hard to remain like as I
would say like uh ethical algo hacking
um but yeah we're working hard I promise
I promise you trust me we are working
very hard to try and find that balance
um and yeah I guess just click on
everything actually that's a solution
just click on everything if you click on
everything then it doesn't matter what
the title is uh you don't need to miss
any of them click on them
all timx Fitness what does a full day in
the life
of what what look like a full day in the
life of of a Chris detail from the time
you wake up until the time you go to bed
do you exercise in the morning do you
practice fasting before during a podcast
split your work up into blocks a couple
of times per day do you work during
weekends all right try and blast through
this quickly uh wake up 7:00 a.m. in the
gym by 740 IAD element and uh some
probiotic stuff first thing before I
leave train get back some sort of
protein shake or some eggs then sit down
at my desk by 9:00 a.m. we'll tend to
catch up because the first video will go
live at 10:00 so we'll check in on that
make sure that everything in terms of
Copy in the slack channels are all
sorted for that episode will go out I'll
be working through admin having
conversations maybe some calls about 12:
midday I'll stop and then begin or like
complete redoing prep for the guest then
I'll record about 400 p.m. that'll go
until about 6 p.m. finish up during that
time I'll have gone for walks taking
more calls done more bits and pieces of
reading all the rest of it and then
usually 6:30 go out for dinner with
friends and then get back and bed by
10:30 that's most days and then on a
weekend uh the I never record on
weekends we I train more on a morning
I'll tend to go out do comedy live shows
all that sort of stuff uh and that's
kind of it so it's kind of heavily
routinized when I'm at home but way less
routinized than it was when I used to
live here which again is crazy that
couch that I'm pointing at which you
totally can't see and you may never
see probably thousands of hours I spent
on that couch journaling meditating
doing doing breath work like writing
reading just thinking about stuff for so
long so if that sounds uh like robotic
whatever I'm doing in Austin given that
that's pretty much every single day that
version of me from a little while ago
was way
worse Mercedes Alvarez
8379 I'm nailing it with the names today
by the way uh when are you going to have
bmth on the Pod all right Bring Me The
Horizon uh just today Jordan fish
announced that he's leaving uh Jordan is
a good friend and I hope that the
departure was amicable I don't know
anything about it um but I'm a massive
fan of the boys and I would love to
bring any of them on olle I've told a
number of times that he needs to come on
we just haven't been in the same place
so we will get him
eventually Logan Mack regarding your
policy of deleting or stopping people's
comments from being seen do you reckon
this in part stems from being an only
child by way of not having to deal with
the constant annoyances of others
reasons previously given are very valid
just a thought all right so to recap uh
season one of why people get banned from
the channel this is my house take your
[__] shoes off like behave in an
appropriate way this doesn't mean that I
expect everyone to be a sycophant or
even agree with me but it means that I
expect people to like behave in a civil
Manner and if I bring some guests on the
show and the comments are just filled
with unthoughtful stupid like name
calling that hasn't got anything to do
with the episode how many times do we go
on and look at a 2 and a half hour
three-h hour long episode and based on
the title and thumbnail someone has
already spewed some half-baked opinion
using an ad homonym or like calling
names or bringing up something which is
unrelated and just being a dick it's
like hey guess what this isn't a nice
environment for anybody to be in and
that's not the way that I want it to be
go someone else's Channel like I I don't
mind if you you only want to contribute
to channels where you can can brain fart
out whatever you want uninterrupted at
all times that's not here so that's what
happened before do I think that this is
my way of not having to deal with the
constant annoyances of others that's so
interesting and I've never thought of it
before and you actually might be right I
don't deal
with frustrations very well and when I
want something to happen if it's
dependent on other people I do find
myself getting quite agitated pretty
quickly so yeah actually I think that
that might contribute to it a little bit
um but more so than that I just want a
really positive environment what was the
first question about negativity on the
internet like I don't want a
cynical audience and there's a button on
the back end of YouTube that's called
hide user from Channel I think it's
called and it means that that person can
still watch they can still comment they
can still like but only they can see
that comment and no one else can and
they're just spewing stuff into the
ether and it's one strike and you're
done
like that's been the policy for over a
year now and if you go on and look at
episodes there is still tons and tons of
criticism so it's not like we're getting
rid of criticism we're just getting rid
of the people that were spoiling the
party for everybody and like you know
what it's like you go onto a channel and
you look at the top few comments and if
the top few comments are stupid you're
like oh this is like a really idiotic
audience I don't want
that sat
chit 111 we need a video on your monk
mode was just talking about that how
timely
um so I got a bit of stick actually uh
like three or four months ago or maybe
even it was at the start of the year and
then it got popped back up again by
podcast cringe a couple of months ago or
a couple of weeks ago um I talked about
an old morning routine that I used to do
which was pretty extensive it was wake
up go for a walk uh element in water
come back sit down Journal breath work
into into meditation into reading into
food prep and it would take during covid
i' like spun it up to like n oh and uh
uh Mobility work as well so it's Ste
Mill's big three for my lower back
during Co I'd got that
to 90 minutes maybe more maybe probably
90 minutes or so to get that
done and I don't disagree all of the
people that were saying in the comments
when it first came out and then when it
popped back up again uh like this is
ridic ulous how uh
like out of touch uh like tell me that
you don't have a job while without
telling me that you don't have a job um
I don't disagree with all of those
things I wasn't suggesting that other
people do it or that it was even
necessarily optimal there are probably
ways that you can enjoy more of your
life and not take up the first two hours
of your day doing like mad bro
self-development stuff however I found
unbelievable success with doing that and
I think it was maybe a counter to Party
Boy Chris that had had his head up his
ass for so long that he needed this like
very
intense pharmaceutical grade dose of
introspection and isolation and
introversion and all of that stuff to
drive it home so for me consider it a
compensatory mechanism but for you know
for a long time dude I'm looking down
there and I can see the stack of
journals that I completed like 11
six-month journals in a row that I
completed daily morning and evening and
these were big they were formative parts
of of me and it was it's I'm not going
to lie about like what I did what I did
during that period was a lot of time on
my own a lot of time without alcohol a
lot of time without partying 500 days
without caffeine all that stuff and it
worked and you know I I I don't disagree
like it's ridiculous it's [__] it's
absolutely insane and almost no one can
do it and and many people might see it
as
hell but it was really good for me and
it ended up making me into a better
person so I think [__] hoay for that
version of Chris Joe Gaffney modern
wisdom primarily focuses on
intellectuals as guests would you be
open to start having people from other
fields on like Fred again theovon or are
you going to leave that to the kind of
Da doac and stick to the intellectual
framework so I mean Mark Norman and
Whitney Cummings are probably going to
be very flattered by you uh calling them
intellectuals but yeah man I I I love
speaking to people from all different
strokes and I don't know for next year
I'm thinking about a little bit more
from the comedy side I was blown away by
Whitney Cummings like look at the
comments on that episode at just
outstanding like people going I can't
like who is this person I was so
impressed by her like she's great I
really really impressed like enjoyed
that
conversation yeah for next year Fred
again would be great would absolutely
adore to speak to him uh theovon is on
my hit list and yeah I think broadening
out the the fields a little bit more
that being said obviously as you go up
and up and up through those echelons
even for someone with a one and a half
million YouTube channel it's still tough
like it's still this big like networking
game and the timing has to be right and
all the rest of it so no yeah uh we'll
be broadening out as we have I think
we've continued to broaden out quite
nicely over the last six years but I won
to stop
mangalo how does your online success
affect your self-image in real life how
do you view yourself today versus Chris
from five years ago Dude these questions
are so good like the Insight that you
guys have from
watching the show and then being able to
work out some hole that's going to be
interesting uh you should be very
everybody that submitted a question
should be very flattered because you you
come up with good questions
how does online success affect your
self-image in real life how do you view
yourself today versus Chris from five
years ago um to be honest man it's it's
like kind of jarring it's that little
sentence that I said at the top um
identity lags Reality by one to two
years so I'm still just catching up to
me moving out to Texas and feeling oh
like I'm a person who deserves to have
an 01 visa and live in America or
whatever um I'm less racked with
self-doubt and uncertainty than I was
before uh I view I view myself as kind
of worthy of my successes which I don't
think I could have said uh probably even
a year ago so that makes me feel good I
like the fact that like I'm not just
riddled with impostor syndrome and and
and and self-doubt uh that's a big
difference a huge difference actually um
but online success is like it's niche
Fame like at the at the very very best
I've got like Micro Niche Fame and if
you put me in the right broy sort of gym
like five guys will come up to me on a
busy Saturday and say hey man I love the
show and that's great like that's a
perfect optimal amount of Fame uh the
difference from Chris five years ago
was so much I mean confidence uh
self-belief the feeling that I deserved
success like an endless Litany of things
and uh it'll be interesting to see where
I'm at in a year's time because it feels
like there's been quite a big change
internally over the last 12 months
Samuel quinnn 2321 would you ever
consider being more disagreeable with
your
guests fair question um I find it tough
to really lean in to the disagreeability
thing you know like the destiny Douglas
Murray style like Michael malice like
real finger pushing stuff uh that's not
my nature um and kind of in the same way
as if you saw some guy that used to
weigh you know 55 kilos and now is
deadlifting like 150 and you'd be like
well £ 150 isn't that much like yeah but
look at where he started the time the
times that I manag to really push the
guests on something with a disagreeable
tone takes an awful lot for me to get
over and that's part of my nature and
it's something that I'm aware of and
it's something that I'm working on as
well to stop being such a people pleaser
even on the show um so yes it's
something I'm actively working on and
for next year will be one of the key
areas of rhetoric that I think I try and
bring into the show more uh that being
said I in my experience if you give
people enough rope they will end up
hanging themselves in any case and being
just sitting back and giving people room
to speak often allows them to like didd
their own philosophy uh more effectively
than you would be able to but I also
don't agree uh don't disagree sorry I
would say yeah uh that's something I'm
working on Cher you appear to have
drifted SLB drifting toward the right
politically with your choice of guests
is this you aligning with your target
audience in an attempt at bringing some
sort of balance or something else um I
don't know I mean like Scott Galloway
Helen Lewis David Pacman Destiny these
people I wouldn't have said are from the
right uh I would say that I'm definitely
more accepted by people who are like
from the center and to the right of
Center um but I mean I've asked I've
been trying to reach out to a ton of
people from the left one of which I can
say is Hassan ABI like I really want to
bring him on I'd love to have a
conversation with him I can't get a
response here's a good story so we were
about to work with a much company we've
never done modern wisdom much and I was
like God six years 1.5 million Subs
pretty cool brand I think modern wisdom
is pretty cool brand
why don't we make some merch out of it
so we found this company and everything
was going to be great and it was a West
Coast merch company but they distributed
internationally and they had a very
female very gen ZZ very left
leaning design team they did a kickoff
call with them and said really great to
say that we brought Chris Williamson on
board and we're going to be doing the
merch for modern wisdom and there was a
mutiny and they literally said if if you
make us do this we're
leaving
so the sensitivity around whatever
positioning I'm supposed to have I mean
like if you think that I'm unspeakable
and Beyond The Pale you're [__] if you
go on the internet um but yeah that it's
tough for me to get those people on that
being
said Scott Galloway one of my favorite
people definitely is like [__] very
very Lefty left uh Destiny the same
Helen Lewis was great she was the Helen
is literally the lady from GQ that like
held Jordan Peterson's feet to the fire
for 2 and 1 half hours so I try and find
balance as best I can Robert Warton
2394 I asked this with no hater Vibe but
why why did you choose to make an
unhealthy energy drink your business
venture I'll be interested to know what
you mean by unhealthy because it's got
zero sugar it's got natural colorings
it's got natural caffeine it's got the
methylated version of balamin which is
one of the B vitamins which is more
easily absorbed by your body it is
completely evidence-backed and I will go
toe-to-toe with anyone in the
evidence-based community on the
formulation of it what I presume that
you're talking about is the fact that we
used a k as the sweetener now if you
look at any any shelf of drinks you will
see akk and aspartame being used very
liberally including in Prime including
in tons and tons of drinks that are much
more famous than us
um I don't think that it's unhealthy by
virtue of the fact that I literally
designed it this way could we have put a
lot of people have said why couldn't you
use Stevia have you ever tried to use
Stevia with a evidence-based formulation
like ours because each one of the
different compounds that we put in has a
different bitterness profile so you've
got cognizin pretty bitter rodol R and
panex jinen taste [__] awful on their
own eleanine can be kind of gritty then
you've got the B vitamins that you need
to load on top plus the caffeine that
needs to go in trying to get that to
taste nice we tried everything I really
wanted to try and make it work with uh
natural sweeters and it didn't so it's I
mean been having it just before I
started it's money this stuff's [__]
dynamite and I'm so proud of it I love
The Branding I love the way it looks I
love what it does everyone that takes it
is super super impressed so uh if it's
not for you if you are so dialed on your
health and fitness regime that the type
of sweetener that you have in your
productivity drink is something that you
have narrowed your health and fitness
goals down to more power to you but it's
not for
me mattas why do you party Vape um I
feel like you've seen me somewhere uh so
yeah when I look we were on tour and I
was in uh Toronto or Vancouver uh
Vancouver I think uh when I drink I've
started vaping uh I do it at comedy clo
shows and I do it at um 10 one nights
out but thankfully I don't go out that
much which means I don't Vape that much
I don't know I'm going to blame it on
Zach Zach Vapes and when he's got one
around I always grab it off him that
being said I'm thinking about doing uh
sobriety for all of 2024 which will also
fix the vaping problem but I don't know
largely because it's fun and because
whoever it was degenerate Chris party
party boy Chris is still in there uh
somewhere and I've got to get my fix you
know if I'm
stop doing fat lines and hard drugs
party vaping is like the PG
equivalent Isaac mango when is Tim Dylan
getting on the show dude I'd love to
bring him on I love that guy he's in and
out of Austin that guy's been in
Austin when I've not been there for the
last three times it's almost as if
someone knows someone in Tim Dylan's
team knows when I'm leaving and then
purposefully places him in the city at
that time but yeah I I'm a huge fan of
his podcast and I would love to bring
him on and hopefully we can make it
happen next year Ali is there any amount
of money which will make you consider
making an only fans
account everyone's got a
price oh ambitious one do you still get
depressed that's an interesting question
um I did for a lot of my
20s I can't remember the last time that
I was um there's little waves of that
those thought patterns do sometimes
burst above the surface a little bit but
it's been a long time like proper proper
depression for me is laid in bed can't
leave make excuses stop doing things
order [__] food don't open the curtains
stay on phone all day or watch screens
nap at least twice three times don't
leave go to bed that night run it back
the next day um I actually think in in
retrospect that it was like acute
burnout rather than Depression was what
was happening to me but uh largely no
and I think
that good health and fitness regime
better climate more friends and a better
sleep and wake pattern um has
made
probably 70% to 90% of the difference D1
and only what
next um good question I guess going into
2024 so book is going to be a priority
for the first six months of next year um
I really need to just get my head down
and get that written because once it's
done then I can you know get back into
other things don't let the show drop
don't take my eye off the ball there's
so many different things that you know
opportunities and why don't you do this
and we could get you as an adviser and
here's an investment and here's a
company that we could start and why
don't you do a course on that we could
do this thing with some partnership with
this
company all of those things are exciting
but they're not the main thing and you
know if you've downloaded my reading
list you'll see that one of the top five
books is essentialism by Greg McKuen and
being an essentialist I.E focusing on
the vital few not the trivial many doing
less but better is easy when you have
fewer things available for you to do
than time to do them in because you can
say yes to everything and still feel
like you've got spare time now the btool
has been flipped upside down and there
are more things that I could do with my
time than time that I have to do them in
and each potential thing for me to do is
like the best thing that I've been
offered ever over and over and over
again uh so it's hard and uh a skill set
that saying no to things is a skill set
that I'm still having to develop so what
next is book for the first half of next
year uh keep doing the show continue to
bring on interesting guests continue to
shoot in a beautiful manner uh the
cinema stuff I adore I think we've
really captured uh a part of the market
and and like a part of the internet from
that kind of didn't exist like no one
was shooting things in super high
quality like us so I'm going to continue
to spin that up um that's kind of it
like if I get to the end of next year
having written a book and just not
stopped my caliber for the show that'll
be great from the outside that doesn't
look like much but from the inside
that's still an absolute [__] ton AOK
and then actually I would like to do to
start releasing a Bunch like a suite of
different courses so we've been talking
about monk mode and like me sitting on
this couch and stuff there was a very
particular sequence of things that I
went through in a very particular way
that I did it I searched for a long time
to find the best in the world for breath
work the best in the world for
meditation the best in the world for
journaling the best in the world for
reading practices and Mobility practices
and Spinal Rehab and training and all
that stuff and if there' been a One-Stop
shop for me to find that in it would
have made my life a lot easier and they
say that you should make products for
the person that you were a few years ago
and that would have been great for me so
maybe I'll start to do something but I
don't know like even the like the idea
of doing courses and things kind of
gives me a bit of a an ick but then I
also think that's just because of the
way that other people talk about it
online rather than the actual value uh
offering that it brings so I'll get over
that maybe that uh interesting things
you should know about what are your New
Year's resolutions I haven't done them
yet this is December 22nd and I haven't
done them so I will sit down next week
and do my annual review which you can
get at Chris willll x.com review for
free Peter wall how long have you been a
CIA plant I think I've upgraded oh CIA
plant is like way high I'm I'm probably
controlled opposition Michael malice has
this hierarchy of the different ways
that
the different ways that glowing experts
Ascend or something and it's like I I'm
pretty sure I'm controlled opposition or
maybe I'm not I'm probably not
interesting enough or important enough
to be controlled opposition yet
areli you always talk about your single
child past social anxiety being bullied
how have you transitioned from that to
running nightclubs that always bugged me
as weirdly
unlikely uh first off always talk about
that interestingly I didn't talk about
that before David goggin's episode that
was the first time that I really opened
up about being bullied and I think and
that kind of real social anxiety stuff
that I had in the past so it's
interesting that that seems at least to
you like it's been
a it's like a Mainstay of who I am
because to me it still feels like a very
recent uh Revelation that I've decided
to kind of open up about myself uh
transitioning from that to running
nightclubs yeah um there's a few people
that have like oh this guy was obviously
popular in school because of either the
way he that he looks or the job that he
P like pivoted into um I don't know like
skepticism around my origin
story maybe I should take it as a
compliment that I seem so well balanced
now that there's no way that I could
have been like a total like
neurode Divergent degenerate artist in
in school but I promise you and if you
ask any of the people that I went to
school with they would they would back
me up um how did I transition from that
into running nightclubs I guess I saw
the opportunity to be someone that
people needed and if people need you
it's kind of the same as them wanting
you and even if people didn't want me
but needed me to get a VIP band that
manifested as me being accepted by the
world and
being uh being given validation and
being given a like a a place
of belonging in some way uh so that PIV
and also don't forget for almost all of
my childhood years I was on the outside
of social networks looking in so I was
observing and working out how different
things moved and why people did things
the way they did and how they moved
between that's what a club promoter does
a club promoter looks at social networks
and works out how to manipulate them so
that you can get people to go to a
different event who's the key taste
maker within that the only difference
between being popular and unpopular with
that is can you get in can you like play
the social game the social dynamics game
of actually being able to communicate
and as soon as you've got that down
you've got this massively increased
level of attention and precision uh and
focus that you have on why people are
the way they are which I think is still
largely why my obsession with human
nature on the podcast evolutionary
psychology all of that stuff is still
here Connor how many of your subscribers
are because of your jawline yeah this
has become a bit of a meme online
someone a bunch of people have had Pops
at me on Twitter about this it's very
interesting it's a very interesting
criticism given that the show is bigger
on Spotify than it is on YouTube and you
can't see me on there uh I mean look
I've chosen to do a thing which is the
least flash least showy like I'm doing
it with a top on uh I'm cropping this
above the arms like when people meet me
in real life they're like wow dude like
you're like less of a skinny [__] than
I thought like you're a bit more jacked
than I thought you were um I think it is
cope to say that the reason that this
podcast is successful is because of my
jaw line the same way as it's cope to
say that it's successful because of uh
love Island I came off of iseland with
an additional 3,000 followers in
201 15 16 whenever I did it uh it was
Tiny and it did nothing and actually put
me back we've lost contracts with
partners and Airlines because the person
that was the key tastemaker found out
that I was on love Island so if you
think that going on love Island helps
and then the jawline
thing I don't know if you think that
Jordan Peterson gets seduced by me doing
a like model face at him uh you might be
unfortunately
surprised Jean Luke Picard is it okay to
put Nikes in the washing machine
thanks sure let's say yes I've managed
to thread the needle of never doing my
own washing pretty much I can do it but
I choose not to uh and I'm 35
so my advice is work out a way where you
don't need to do your own
washing Jason Stone didn't you only have
1 million about 3 weeks ago I think it
was about four months ago but yeah it's
been the last few months have just been
crazy which is also beautiful but
disquieting and uh I'm holding on for
dear life Al the dating advice for gurus
online seems to boil down to just be
successful bro given that women rate 80%
of men as physically unattractive and
50% of men are below average
intelligence what's the advice for those
40% of men that's
interesting
the bar is set unbelievably low like the
average American man is obese divorced
and with less than 1K in the
bank that is a very very low bar uh I
think that the internet over indexes on
objective metrics of success and doesn't
account for what happens in person you
will see regularly people and guys that
are charismatic funny sexy in person
batting way outside of their league if
you were to just look at them from an
online perspective basically I would say
don't overthink what the internet says
because the reality of dating for almost
everybody if you talk to people that
aren't terminally online and ask them
about their dating experiences and then
talk to the people who are terminally
online these two don't spend all that
much time getting close that being said
it is there are some genetic uh
like truths
uh that are rough to get around but
again dude if you go to the gym three
times a week for a year you're probably
in the top percentile of all Fitness
people on the planet if you spend 300
bucks on a relatively okay wardrobe with
some blacks some whites some navies and
some Grays you're probably better
dressed than most of the guys that
you're going to walk past like the bar
is so [__] low so the dating advice
from gurus online boils down to just be
successful bro it's like just try a bit
and you will already be probably a six
or seven out of
sabinal who is the man with the most
insane work ethic that you have known
hosi obvious answer but that guy's
ability to go and go and go and not stop
is [__] ungodly
and it's it's impressive it's very
um it's
admirable to see uh and also uh largely
unrealistic for most people to achieve
uh ham cheese lettuce mayo
sandwich uh question why the F did you
start selling a snake oil tonic drink
it's not a tonic it's called neonic um I
would be interested to know what the
snake oil thing part of that is given
that it is completely evidence-based and
the main movers from a neut Tropics
perspective are probably the most
researched and well-backed that there
are uh but the reason I started selling
it is because I wanted it and it didn't
exist so I made it and I figured if I've
made it for myself I might as well give
it to other people
too Fran copz 167 why haven't you
brought in an expert in metaphysics or
spirituality like Jo do dispenser or
someone like that or you just don't
believe in these things please it's an
honest question greetings from Venezuela
greetings to you too Franco Perez
I love how I don't know whether it's
Google translate or just kind of a an
unnecessarily formal way um of of
putting stuff across but I love how like
please it's an honest question it's like
so like unnecessarily uh nice in the way
that it's done just in case he like
offended me uh and meanwhile there's
like armies and armies of people on hide
user from Channel just like spewing
[__]
um I am a fan of Dr Dr Joe dispenser and
uh I am trying quite hard to bring him
on the show so if your metaphysics and
spirituality is aligned appropriately if
our astral Realms have worked in sync
with the retrograde of Venus you may get
him sooner than you
think J Road dog one more
African-Americans on the show please
sure suggest some I would love to bring
some African-Americans on speak speaking
of that not sure if you saw um people
kicked off about spotify's uh top 10
shows uh not being sufficiently
ethnically diverse and there was a bunch
of people putting ninja emojis
uh Ninja I think is referring to how
many African Americans that were or
people of African descent we can put in
a politically correct way uh where are
all of my ninjas at was a question that
was asked super top comy loads and loads
and loads of people it's like if you
actually look at it Steven
is like I think garan mother or
something like that Jetty isn't white uh
the chick that does the Ted thing is I'm
pretty sure she's Asian so all of the
people that were like this isn't
sufficiently representative like it's
full of white people I wonder how
stevenh and Jay and the Ted lady feel
about being like white people
funny
peral SMI Sima if you had a son what
would you name him I like red rising and
the lead protagonist in that is called
Darrow I think Darrow is a [__] dope
name for a kid you're not having a loser
if your son is called Darrow like it's
impossible to grow up and be called
Darrow and not be an absolute stud so
daro R pit tiala no question just a
suggestion make a different channel for
Clips it gets messy I've seen many
creators making different clips channels
and chips channels getting more views
than the main one Clips channels getting
more views than the main one um you have
but that is survivorship bias and if you
look at all of the other Clips channels
that are part of other like moderately
successful podcasts you'll see that they
get dog [__] plays My Philosophy from
the very beginning was when people bate
their channels off and have one main
podcast feed and one Clips feed you get
a underperforming main podcast Channel
and a total dog [__] performing chips
Clips Channel look I'm [__] doing it
now chips Channel um you do that and
that wasn't something that I thought
structurally made that much sense if
you're a fledgling podcaster I would
advise not doing it I would put
everything that you have into one
channel it makes it way easier to do
scheduling it makes it way easier for
accounting it makes it way easier
operationally and it's worked for us
maybe I could have had a 1.1 million sub
main Channel and a 500K Clips Channel
but like what the [__] am I doing with
the clips Channel I'm just all all for
one Nate 6795 are you the on it
guy I swear I recognize you from an ad
from them with
Rogan that's or Marcus
that's someone does he look like me I
don't think he does we we both live in
Austin we' both got short hair sometimes
he's covered in tattoos he's three
inches taller than
me uh anyway maybe I'm wrong either way
love your podcasts I would love to see
more content creators like streamers
Gamers and also comedians are always
great to watch bilur would love to get
Bill b Bill bur on trying to get Hassan
ABI on uh I don't know who else from
streamers like Charlie would be great
Ludwig would be great um I don't think I
watch many of the streamers and then all
of the chick streamers are getting
themselves in bother at the moment so
stay
clear George Mack what have you changed
your mind about most in the last 12 to
months
o um hormonal birth control was a huge
one last year that was a really big one
uh I you know coming from a a nightlife
background you just presume that like a
lot of people having casual sex it's
probably pretty good to ensure that we
don't have accidental pregnancies and
then I just learned about the impact
that this stuff has on women's Mental
Health on their bodies it can lock in a
type of protein folding uh during
formative years of brain development in
the brain that causes women to be more
predisposed to anxiety and all sorts of
stuff so skepticism around hormonal
birth control was a big one last year
this year has probably
been
epigenetics uh just I thought that
epigenetics was like the quantum healing
of the of the genetic behavioral
genetics world or just the straightup
genetics World um I thought it was
[__] and I was wrong so uh
epigenetics this year and hormonal birth
control last year Simon Evans could you
have achieved the success without
leaving the UK no no I I have often
thought this did I need to make the move
to Austin in order to be able to do the
things and could I have repurposed it or
whatever whatever but it's like a
million tiny
changes in exposure and who you're
hanging around with and the
conversations you have and the people
that you run into too and then the
change in my work rate and inspiration
and enthusiasm because I'm around a
different type of culture and then the
change in weather and the all of that
stuff uh so largely
no the crypto Journal how would you
recommend a podcaster or content creator
builds Their audience without going on
love island or a similar godforsaken
reality TV show
again I would go as far as to say that
love Island was a net negative for my
podcasting Journey it gave me nothing I
started this podcast with nothing there
were days
in March or April after we' launched and
we were one episode per week deep there
were days where we did zero total plays
across audio and YouTube zero none no
plays right so it wasn't like we had
some huge launch and it gave us a
catapult uh so I would recommend that
you do it the same way that I did I
think the way that I did it is the most
reliable way to do it which is don't
stop if you don't stop you will
eventually get good presuming that you
have the raw materials to be good at it
uh building an audience is tough but
consistency is the rarest thing in all
of content creation because everybody
wants an audience now and it's hard to
get an audience now but it's actually
pretty easy to get an audience in six
years time Charles do you have a book or
books you've read more than three three
times more read more three or more times
in the past decade if yes this is the
[__] thing if if someone puts a typo
in their question it makes me sound like
an idiot when I try like who's this
keton that can't read the questions it's
like no no that's how the question was
written do you have a book or books
you've read more three or more times in
the past decade nailed it if yes uh what
keeps you bring what keeps bringing you
back to that book if no is there one you
think fits the criteria for you I'm
also I'm also jetlagged okay I'm jet
lagged I didn't sleep on the plane over
so forgive me if the Precision is a
little bit
off essentialism by Greg mchu and I must
have read at least twice or three times
the almanac of Nal rant I must have read
at least two or three times Red Rising
my favorite fiction book I must have
read at least three
times those are probably
them uh if yes what keeps me bringing me
back to that book uh there are lessons
in essentialism and the almanac of noval
ravikant that I haven't yet learned or
implemented so I need to be reminded of
it and Red Rising is just [__]
awesome Ben which episode did you feel
the most uncomfortable about releasing
to the world wow that's a good question
that's the first time I've ever been
asked that which question which
episode it's hard it's real hard when
people ask about you know which episode
across the entire library because it's 7
what's it 720 or something now like such
a huge number and I can like a lot of
them I've forgotten um but recently I
can give you one recently the Patrick B
David episode I actually I really wasn't
happy with my performance on it um I
wasn't happy with the way it flowed I
didn't think like I'd per I didn't feel
like I'd perform particularly well I was
imprecise with my speech I hadn't pushed
him where I'd wanted to I hadn't opened
up the way that I'd wanted to it was
just messy there some days like you just
you some days you just don't hit it
right uh when you go out onto the field
of play and you know everything just
feels a little bit off it's like getting
The Yips I suppose as a a sportsman and
uh I just didn't feel good and I
remember we finished the episode and
we'd done this like crazy period of we
were over in La we'd done all of the
episodes in LA and then we flew over to
to uh Florida and then we recorded with
Patrick and we'd had all of this travel
and we' nailed it and everything had
gone great and I was I was like in a bit
of a slump I was driving home or I was
in the Uber on the way to the airport
know just feeling a bit disgruntled with
myself and I had to take myself to one
side and have a little word and I texted
Dean and told him and he was like dude I
don't know what's up I don't know what
you mean like everything seemed to go
great as far as I could see and I was
like yeah I know but it's not my best
and it could have been better than all
the rest of it so not for any particular
reason other than I wasn't happy with my
performance on the episode that pbd one
um still you know I'm sure it listened
great but if you go back and listen to
it see if you can pick up on me [__]
the bed a ton of times
cognitively the Zen master my feeling of
pure passion and my feeling of pure
emotional pain seemed to be
indistinguishable this started after I
really leveled up in my efforts I can't
tell if I should lean into it or be
cautious with it do you know what this
is my feeling of pure passion and my
feeling of pure emotional pain seem to
be indistinguishable wow that's very
interesting
uh I am hesitant about giving this
sounds like it could be the beginning of
schizophrenia or bipolar disorder or
something so I'm like a hesitant about
giving uh bestowing any Bro Science to
someone that might need a more educated
eye my sense is always to try and
investigate without leaning into it a
little bit more before you lean into it
too much because if you lean into it too
much there is no undoing
that so maybe do I would focus on some
journaling and I would ask yourself
questions about like what is it that's
causing the emotional pain what is it
that's causing the passion where does
the passion come from how can I bate
these two out and just ask yourself some
questions sit with a bit of silence and
see what comes up uh hopefully what you
should be able to do is use that passion
to if if pain and passion feel the same
way you basically don't have pain
anymore if you can
just alchemize anytime that the pain
arises that's just passion it's like the
um it's Whitney Cummings thing she says
uh no sorry uh
[__] God damn it who does dumpster
fire who does dumpster fire the
podcast
[__] who is it
[__] this see this is jet lag this is
jet lag for you anyway I'm not nervous
I'm excited is the tagline that uh that
name's just not going to come to me I'm
going to bail out
uh I'm not nervous I'm excited is the
same as I'm not in pain this is just
passion and you should be able to
repurpose it God see that's that's
another one just not enough sleep [__]
the bed Steve cardos cardoso what are
some mantras you regularly return to
um this is what hard feels like from
Alex is [__] brilliant
like did you expect that the thing that
you're trying to do this great
achievement that you wanted to do that
you were going to be proud of did you
expect it to not be hard no all right
this is what hard feels like and it just
repurposes any time that you encounter
challenge or difficulty from this is a
bug to this is a feature it's the entry
price I decided to pay when I wanted to
go and do this thing so that's probably
been one of my most common this year
Simon dweight what gets you to 3 million
honestly bro like if I don't put my foot
in my mouth which again like I did this
last year I said maybe the exact same
episode or something similar a question
about like what's your plan for
2023 and I said I want to fist [__] the
internet I wouldn't bet against me um
really it's all mine to lose at the
moment I think like everything that we
touch seems to go relatively well and I
can I have the team we need to develop
the team a little bit more I need a
chief of staff and like some other
things so that I don't need to be
involved day-to-day quite so
much but we have the team in terms of
raw materials we have the platform we
have the brand Equity I have the skill
set to just grow this thing essentially
infinitely I think uh and the only thing
really that can take it down is me so if
I'm looking back on this in a couple of
years time and thinking you idiot why
did you do X Y or Zed that caused you to
be totally cancelled and stop
then so be it but what gets me to 3
million is just me continuing to do the
thing that I've always done and that's
what I intend to do Marcus Phillipson
will new tonic ever be available in
Sweden dude we are trying to roll this
thing out globally as much as we can
we're out of stock again like this I had
to get this is a good story I had to get
George to bring this
puppy he bought 10 cases that's a good
friend buy 10 cases of your your buddy's
new drink he brought two up yesterday so
I got my friend to buy my product off
his own back separately then bring it to
me then leave it at my house so I could
drink it that's like the best like uh
Arbitrage opportunity ever uh but yeah
we're going to try and get it
everywhere being able to create
sufficient product is proving really
hard because the demand is super high
but it'll be there soon light truck
light light blue truck do the English
accent went alone or is it just a
[Laughter]
bit Ah could you imagine if I got off
this and just cracked out like some deep
south accent uh no unfortunately or
fortunately I'm cursed with this all the
time gorav what is it all for that's
open to interpretation uh from a
question perspective and very
existential
but increasingly I think that it is all
for fun like if you're not having fun
doing the things that you're doing like
what what's the [__] point honestly
like especially you know I'm speaking of
someone who's managed to achieve way
more success than he ever thought he was
going to and it's like still going I'm
still in the throws of it right so I
don't know where it's going to come into
land if at all or crash land perhaps as
well but you can you can sacrifice so
much on route to achieving anything that
you want to that you look back and you
go what was the what was the [__]
point like there's honestly so much
satisfaction in the fun of getting to
wherever it is and almost none of it in
the achievement of whatever it is so
right now what is it all for it's for at
the moment for me setting up a life in
which I can have more fun that is one of
my mantras for
2024 Jim Knight how much have the cinema
episodes played a part in securing the
high-profile guests you've had in the
past few months I know several probably
came through the gym shot connection but
did the appeal of a ridiculously
beautiful recording help with getting
Joo and doggin Etc so with Goggins I
know that it definitely did um
Joo I don't think so I think the channel
is kind of able to run under its own
momentum now although Joo was wow would
have been 400k something like that so
significantly smaller
and much less impressive of a roster so
yeah maybe maybe it has contributed a
good bit um I think it's cool like if if
I go to someone you know that's a highly
sought-after guest like Dr Joe dispenser
or Kyle from the nek boys or someone and
I say hey I want to do something with
you that you typically wouldn't do I
need 4 hours of your time but I'm going
to drop 30 grand and make the most
beautiful podcast that you've ever been
a part of like better than you can make
yourself because I have the team and we
have the skill set to be able to bring
this together and you don't even need to
leave your city it's hard to say no to
and
um like that that strategy makes me feel
satisfied I think the guests genuinely
love it I think they feel proud of what
they're a part of and it's cool and it's
genuinely novel like I don't I don't
think anyone's doing it the way that
we're doing it on YouTube at the moment
and I enjoy it and it's going to get
better this year it's going to get spun
up even harder so hopefully you will see
even more crazy like go back and watch
the Chris Bumstead episode we made some
errors on that from a production
perspective but largely it looks like a
scene out of cyberpunk 2077 it's so
cool uh where are we here Osama bin
balling oh my [__] god that is
the Osama bin balling was your
appearance on Joe Rogan's podcast a
pivotal moment for your own brand and
how does this experience relate to
building friendships and situations
where you might not be the most
knowledgeable um yeah it was it's like a
seal of approval right you get stamped
from the king or whatever you are
bestowed he sort of TAPS the sword on
either shoulder and say is like this is
one of the people that you should look
out for presuming that you don't [__]
the bed on the episode I think I managed
to avoid doing that um it was it was an
important moment and I think that it it
it genuinely kind of does open doors but
not in the immediate like you just get
this ton of influx of things just that
people see you in a different way and
you become part of a relatively
exclusive Club I mean I don't know Joe's
done like 2,000 episodes but including
all of the repeat guests and stuff I
reckon he's only had maybe 12200 people
on the show so it is quite a small group
and that was useful how does this
experience relate to building
friendships in situations where you
might not be the most knowledgeable are
you saying that I'm not the most
knowledgeable
in uh I'm not sure I I'm not quite sure
what that means
uh I don't know what that means I'm
going to have to bail out James do you
ever resonate inwardly with a feeling
like impostor syndrome that although
having a platform known for appc
knowledge and wisdom that somehow it's
present in your guests but that you're
still on a journey to attain wisdom
yourself so this gap for sure between
the people that I speak to and their
level of competence and insight uh and
me is something that I am fully aware of
like on a daily basis uh I have made a
career out of being the most stupid
person in the room permanently and I'm
every single time that I sit down I'm
reminded of that fact
and yeah I
interestingly that's never actually
given me impostor syndrome like oh these
people are whatever than me more rich or
famous or or successful or aidite or
like knowledgeable or whatever than me
um and I also think that it's not my job
I've never once ever ever posited myself
as having it all sorted out or even
having it slightly sorted out having a
part of any part of it sorted out ever
um I think that one of the reasons that
hopefully this resonates with you guys
is that I am on the journey and I'm like
leaving the breadcrumbs behind including
the ones that uh like crap where I go I
I tried to do this thing and I failed or
this was a strategy that I attempted and
it didn't work
or whatever like all of those things all
of those failures and all of those
insights are only able to be born out
largely because of how difficult I find
things and how like useless I've been so
um
no I I actually think it's been pretty
reassuring but I can see how if I
posited myself as some sort of Guru or
some you know like great Insight around
anything that you're supposed to do
Beyond simply this is my experience this
is what I've learned works and doesn't
work for me and maybe you should try it
uh it would be very different Andrew
Waterhouse besides the drink and tour
are there other products you'd like to
sell in future like JP does his books
courses SB has a book TV shows Etc um I
am done with
TV what's the knock on wood Famous Last
Words uh but I'm done with TV it's so
unenjoyable it is [__] awful to watch
this
slow clunky Behemoth of a huge [__]
production chunder along and then say
right guys we're going to go for Take
One and can we go back and we're going
to have to run that again and blah dude
it sucks then you look at YouTube and
it's so fast PAC past and agile and no
time it's lean there's no time wasted so
TV can get [__] um Jordan books
courses so book yep like I say by the
start of 25 you will have something that
I'm very proud of and I'm really excited
about uh courses I mentioned earlier on
there is a bit of like ick and you know
the distaste that people had when I
decided to release a drink that I wanted
and I needed and then said hey I've
spent 12 once developing this there's a
lot of criticism although it's been a
lot more uh Hollow because of how legit
the product is and maybe that's the
lesson that
my dis Qui around the potential of
releasing a course is because the world
of courses has been
heavily consumed and filled by people
who release courses that aren't really
that worthwhile
and if I was to do it if I do it the
same way that we did new tonic which is
like the best in class absolute best in
class at a price point that's that's
fair and all the rest of it then what is
there to
be ashamed of so yeah I I would love to
do some courses and you
know there is like in order for us to
continue to make this thing move I need
to sit down in the seat and that means
that I never get a break from sitting
down in the seat and I love sitting down
in the seat but there may come a time
where I just want to take like a two
week break and keep things ticking over
so like what does that mean I don't know
we we'll wait and see but courses
courses and books would be great on the
on the horizon uh Campbell what would an
elite five episode start a pack of
modern wisdom look like for a new
listener oh that's cool all right so we
need something motivational we need
something epic we need something
underground that no one knows
about probably need a story from Left
Field
so I would say it would be a disservice
not put Goggins in so I think Goggins is
the first
one I think any Ginder Bogle episode as
the second for human nature
Insight I
think
maybe hosi
2 uh from just like a straight up uh
motivational human nature
standpoint uh Rory otherland 2 the one
that I recorded when I was in Dubai is
just outstanding and one of the funniest
episodes I've ever
done and I want like a story based one I
did an episode with the guy that the
mortanian was written about um and it's
basically just a 90-minute monologue of
him explaining his situation so that's
your five episode starter pack that
that's kind of difficult to work
out Bo Sanderson how do you find that
you were able to be more Curious
specific specifically on a topic that
you want to learn about but isn't
particularly as exciting for you as
another topic how do you find that you
are able to be more
Curious not entirely sure what that
means but for me it's just internal like
I I can't stop myself I want to find out
everything I want to find out why the
sky is that color and why the bird moves
in that way and why that person uses
their left hand not their right hand to
eat cake and all of the things I want to
know them all and it's a blessing and a
curse
um when it comes to trying to make
yourself more Curious to learn a topic
Which is less exciting than another one
my advice unless it's for a degree or a
course that you kind of don't get to
choose is bin off the other topic which
isn't as exciting and just focus on all
the exciting ones that's the simplest
solution Boy Wonder do you work out your
draw muscles with one of them chewy
things to look like that uh no and I'm
pretty fat at the moment like I'm one of
I mean the fattest slowest smallest that
I've been in probably ever like since I
was maybe 24 or 25 so uh again I know
maybe if the the internet's correct if
all that you need to do to build a
podcast is just use one of them chewy
things to work your jaw muscles uh but
no um that being said I think it's jaws
of size I'm pretty sure that they kind
of illegally used a video of Andrew
huberman talking about
either them or an analgous product and
then uh maybe they had to do a cease and
deist I feel like hubman and them got
got in bothered for some reason or
Andrew sued them on some [__] I don't
know what Sven what is something that
everybody in the
productivity in the productivity
business believes will get them success
but is completely
wrong so I think that there's an
overreliance on Leverage and I've seen
this in the content creator world and
it's something that I'm also uh
as the revenue from the show allows me
to finally not need to just do
everything myself it's something that
I'm very cognizant of myself
too when everyone read the almanak Nal
rabant they believed that leverage was
just the most important thing that you
can force
multiply your inputs to outputs through
Code Media labor Capital whatever the
other one
is but what it caused lots of people to
do is take that eye off the ball and
take that eye off the main thing which
is the most important thing to them so
they started to Outsource and try and
get leverage on the main thing that they
do for instance there are like three
things that I need to get right I need
to choose the right guests so I can't
Outsource the guest bucking uh uh
process or at least the guest selection
process I suppose
I need to have a great conversation so I
can't Outsource the research process and
it needs to be framed right to get
people to click on it on the internet so
I try to touch as I said earlier on I
touch all of the titles and thumbnails
that go out at least almost all of them
so those are areas in which Leverage is
really hard for me to
apply but they're also the most timec
consuming right if I get someone else to
do all my guest booking or someone else
to do all my research or someone else to
do all the titles and thumbs I'd free up
like 20 hours a week 30 hours a week
probably so I understand why people are
tempted to do
that but it's also the exact wrong place
to do it so leverage used in the wrong
way to get people to extract themselves
from the most important thing that their
business does that's what it is
franchisco
eramus how has the growth of your social
media influenced changes in your
personality or thought processes that's
an interesting question so I guess you
know depending on where you came in from
uh there's questions from Twitter here
from YouTube from
Instagram um depending on where you came
in from you have a different view of
like me or what I do uh there's some
people I found this out the other day
there's tons of people that subscribe to
my newsletter that don't even know I did
a podcast literally don't know I did a
podcast they just like the writing or
hated the writing and just like to hate
read it I don't know
uh
so it's it's nice it's very flattering
for people to come up and say nice
things um it's made me a little bit more
skeptical in a way that I wish I could
stop about whether new people have my
best interests at heart um and again
it's that thing from the very top where
I was like no one teaches you about how
to deal with scrutiny or fame or
criticism or or attention or any of that
stuff people just are more interested in
you you and you don't know how to deal
with it and you become skeptical of
whether or not they have what like why
and you think back to a previous version
of you and what you think is well this
person wouldn't have been interested in
the previous version of me so the only
reason they're interested in me now is
because they want something and maybe if
they want something that means that they
don't have my best interest at heart and
that means I should be skeptical of them
and that is kind of a dangerous mindset
to get in I think
because
you want to assume the best from people
especially if they're being nice to you
so I understand why the songs talking
about No New Friends especially for
people who are obviously like infinitely
more famous than I
am because it gets around this problem
if you don't have any any new friends
you don't ever have to question whether
or not new people have your best
interest at heart now it also means that
you maybe don't question whether or not
the old people have your best interests
at heart but that's one thing I want to
stop like I I don't want to be skeptical
of people people just because they're
being nice to me and because I imagine
this version of the past life where they
wouldn't have been nice to another
version of me that wasn't that didn't
have a a big following or or whatever uh
so that's one of them I
guess metah Helix how do you intuitively
adapt your interviewing style and or
questions on the Fly based on your
guest's responses you're very well
researched prepared and methodical thank
you but sometimes achieving the optimal
conversation flow is challenging like
Peterson yes Jordan is uh like boxing a
southpaw a little bit Le the last one he
was very disciplined the second episode
I did with him he was it was way more
southp and we were talking over each
other and it was messy and I didn't I
wasn't as happy but the most recent one
flowed pretty much perfectly like if
you're ever having a conversation you
can see this when you're really really
attuned with someone the the quantum
healing people would say that like
you're vibrating at the same level or
whatever
um it's if you're having a conversation
and you're able to get single words into
their sentence that were the word or an
analogous word to the one that they were
about to use and then they continue the
sentence awesome like me and Johnny from
propane have this quite a lot he's one
of the most even though we're quite
different people he's one of the most
attuned in terms of cadence that me that
of anybody that I speak to and a lot of
the time we'll be talking back and forth
and he'll be about to say something and
I'll dip in with the word or whatever it
is and it works brilliantly um that
being said adapting the interviewing
style or whatever is just not having too
much of a preconceived idea about where
it's going to go it's like I'm sitting
down with this person today I have a
game plan of where I think would be
interesting to take it based on my
research of what they do and the
intersection of what they do and what
I'm interested in and we'll see if that
then diagram goes and if within the
first 5 minutes like in a sports game if
that just gets thrown out of the window
said well guess what like we're not
talking about the thing that I thought
we were talking about today that's why
you do research you do research not so
you have a list of questions but so you
know the person's body of work and after
a while to be honest as well like
700 episodes deep I've done so many like
literally thousands of hours of of this
now I've always got a story from someone
from the past or some idea or Insight or
study or whatever that I've already
learned that I can use so if someone
wants to go down one rabbit hole it's
been very long time since someone's
given me an entirely new like completely
new [__] hell this is total fresh
snow it's been a long time since uh
that's happened so I think it's a
combination of preparation not being
too like contrived or or or uh
pre-planning with the process and then
just going where it
goes
uh
M what is a question you regret not
asking a guest uh and number two what is
your pre-show ritual pre-show ritual is
pretty simple um when I get to do it
it's a five-minute vocal warm-up that
Miles my speech coach got me to do which
still to this day is great at just
getting my tongue moving and making sure
that I'm nice and precise with my speech
and getting my uh my mind moving um
usually don't eat for
about two hours before if I can because
it makes me a bit more sluggish another
one of the reasons that I'm not doing
too well today I'm like looking through
the cupboards in my kitchen in Newcastle
for something that isn't my housemates
that he needs or massively out of date
and there like weater Bic so I'm like
fueled by
poor sleep neonic and Weetabix today
don't know whether you have wabix in
America anyway it's a pretty Elite
serial but probably not great if that's
all you've had uh what is a question
that you not that you regret not asking
a guest uh certainly one that comes to
mind from Recently was Peterson um he
did something which is technically
referred to as Jesus smuggling on our
episode um and he has this idea of like
if you believe that one thing can be
more good than another thing then you
believe that God exists because God is
the most good thing that can exist and I
didn't understand at the time and what I
wanted to say was mate I might be being
stupid here but that just that just
sounds like a value hierarchy rather
than God uh and I didn't because I
didn't want to sound
stupid and then I spoke to Alex okona
who's like the most knowledgeable person
on this kind of conversation that I know
of and he just said that's exactly the
question that you should have asked so I
regret not asking that because I didn't
want to seem foolish uh Chris Le
poin hi Chris how rewarding does it feel
given the problem you've described
before about your friend conversion rate
that a lot of people you interview have
become good friends interviewed
Illustrated well in your recent
conversation with Rob Henderson so yeah
I met a million people across my
nightlife career and I had a handful of
friends here in Newcastle which means
that my friendship exposure to
conversion ratio wasn't exactly
fantastic and uh it's unbelievably
rewarding man like it's the opportunity
to turn your Idols into Rivals and then
Rivals into friends is awesome and then
sometimes you don't need to go to the
rivals bit first you can just go
straight to the Friends bit but look I
it feels great um you basically get to
create your own social network you're
like who do I want to be friends with
well that's a person that I respect and
that's a person that's interesting so
I'll just try and invite them on my
podcast and maybe they'll become friends
with me so yeah it's it's awesome hi
Chris which Joe Rogan episode features
the layers of paint that you frequently
refer to I think it was mine I think it
was the episode that he did with me
although I may be wrong or I may have
just made it up Chris
Miracle very very clever my question is
which guest would you love to have on
Modern wisdom most love to have on
Modern wisdom and why uh Naval is still
top of the list man that guy elusive
elusive elusive Naval um he's still on
sabatical post Rogan but uh yeah I
uh I would love to speak to him I think
that it's the greatest podcast episode
that's ever been made his episode on
Rogan and I would love to run that back
go all out full Cinema setup for him so
we'll wait and
see uh Captain Reese you talk about
people growing themselves from $1 to
100K has a set of skills it is has a set
of SK I've been [__] diddled by a bad
question again or again but than going
to 10 million type frame what skill sets
do you think you will have to learn to
adopt to get to to be to get to I'm
going to have to bail out of it I mean
that's to get to 1 million sub we're
already at 1 million Subs we're I'm
moving down I'm moving down Sean Spooner
Mark Manson says identity lags Reality
by one to two years so in some ways
you're the Chris with 247,000
subscribers who hasn't yet interviewed
Jordan Peterson or jocker willink or
David Goggins you haven't done a soldout
tour or launched new tonic or been on
Rogan with that said how are you finding
the blistering pace of change in your
life right now does this new reality
feel like reality
yet that's a great question
um it feels kind of like it it is pretty
disquieting it's like you know when you
get to the top of a roller coaster and
you sort of everything gets weightless
and you do this it feels a little bit
like that um
but I'm getting used to it um
and the SK thankfully I've got people
around me that kind of keep my feet on
the ground and also it's so much easier
to be like this type of like Niche
internet Fame because you don't see it
in person and I can also see having done
the live shows how as a rock star you
become completely detached or maybe a
comedian you become completely detached
from the world because all right
well all of these people just adoring
thousands and thousands of people
whereas you know what's 3,000 comments
on a YouTube video like it's a lot of
comments but it doesn't hit you in the
same way that 3,000 people turning up in
a theater and talking to you does so
yeah um
reality
is unreal in many ways but I'm getting
used to it Ben Rogan part two happening
next week uh it wasn't um but I'd love
to go back on um I'm very very hesitant
about suggesting to Joe that I come back
on that is like a thing that people do
hey man like I'm back in town and why
don't we like get an episode recorded
that makes me feel quite nervous to do
that but yeah I uh I think hopefully
next year that would make me very
happy Dez do you get nervous before
recording a podcast um it's very rare
now last time was probably Sam Harris um
and that was a little bit it arose and
then it went away and that was mostly
because he was late um I think it was
like 15 minutes late and in the 1550
minutes I was waiting it like started to
spin up a little bit
uh but
yes I've managed to largely get rid of
that of that nervousness beforehand
which is just you know the undeniable
stack of proof that you are who you say
you are it worked well uh Matt oldfields
tipping in the US I'm actually in
Bahamas but I understand same protocol
you have tax and 15% service added to
printed Bill and then below you were
offered to leave extra gratuity service
which you write in there with depend
that they leave is it customary to leave
an extra tip unfortunately Matt yes it
is and it is any less than 15% is
usually seen as a bit of a snub uh 10%
is basically like a you've Cur one out
in the middle of the restaurant uh and I
typically try and go for between like
around about 20% seems pretty pretty
pretty right all right I'm going to
round it out there ladies and gentlemen
I appreciate you thank you um for all of
the subs and all of the support this is
the end of
2023 and it's been the crazy year and I
have no idea where we're going to be in
12 months time but I know that I'm still
going to be doing this so thank you very
much for tuning in
peace